right as we continue southern command
rush limbaugh eib headquarters this is
this is
it this is where you do your show it
really is every day there's an ordinance
down here in palm beach cannot work from
your home
and so which is fine i need to get you
know one but but it is the case so we
built this and it's like a living room
home office or okay but can i do one
thing personal
every time i'm on your show people ask
me what this
is i get emails what is this right your
cochlear implant well yeah it's a direct
line to the west wing is what it is
now these are these are cochlear
implants i'm deaf i'm
i'm 100 deaf and i can only hear
bionicle with these
very quickly human ear has 35 000 hair
cells each they determine the frequency
and the sensitivity of the human
hearing i don't have any minor dead they
laid down and died
autoimmune so i have eight man-made
biological electrodes
uh or bionic electrodes that that try to
do what 35 000 hair cells do
and uh it's a miraculous thing i if this
had happened
if i'd lost my hearing 15 years before i
did have been the end of my career
because the tech hadn't been
admitted so it's really fortunate um
and i look at it as a as something to be
extremely grateful i remember in that
interim time not to get too distracted
we got a lot to talk about
and i do radio as you do i do not know
how it's possible
because like most people in radio djs
talk shows
i'm cranking that thing up yeah you know
and dramatic hearing loss
you know after 30 years i did three
months
totally deaf i couldn't get surgery done
because i had an infection so three
months
so you rely on how your voice feels
right you have to consciously tell
yourself
don't when you can't hear you speak up
right so you have to tell yourself now
well i
asked them i asked the doctors if i
don't do this
can i speak normally for the rest of my
i said no
you will you will if you can't hear
yourself speak you'll end up sounding
like somebody
who's never heard before so you've got
to do the implants but that that's what
they are
and and they're um they're really were a
career saver thank you
thank god you're still here going strong
30th anniversary which was a big deal
for those of us that followed behind you
it's a big deal
because you did forge a path for all of
us um and we all owe you a debt of
gratitude that's
that's why really i wanted to be here
explain the trump phenomenon
maybe we have uh a more unique
perspective
because we both knew him way before he
ever thought about running right well
i don't think it's hard to understand
the trump phenomenon at all
if if you are not poisoned and i use the
word like kind of an exaggeration if
you're not affected by
inside the beltway or washington
establishment thinking understanding
trump's easy
it's elite versus real people it it's
somebody that is fearless and willing to
fight against the things that no
republican has been willing to fight
against war or defend
he's got an engaging personality he
doesn't offend people
the left thinks he does because they act
offended but trump just makes people
laugh
they can't get over the fact that he's
likable because they
hate him they despise him i saw the
other never
are we allowed to mention competing
cable networks
because you dominate everything they're
just a bunch of you
little brian stelter over on cnn
actually he's actually been somewhat
nice to me there are exceptions to it
but complaining that the president's
talking too much
the president is in the media too much i
said these guys
demand and pray access and you know what
because he's
polluting the air he's lying
he's distorting and he's not giving us
enough time to catch up with him and to
correct him let's just keep going
president trump he's dominating these
people
he's frustrating them they've lost their
monopoly they the the elizabeth warren
thing the focus proves
they can't shape public opinion anymore
via narrative and they are frustrated as
they can be about that he doesn't need
them
no part of the process part of what's
going on here i believe and all of this
i do call it abnormality we're up
against
psychological disorder abnormality that
is disguised as political issues
and we talk about the meat it's never
been this
abusively biased well it's not even
biased
well we're so far beyond bias these
people are part of the agenda i think
they
i think they run it i think they are the
people that orchestrate it
run it uh in fact even give some
marching orders to each other
the point is uh trump has just got them
bamboozled and they're i think part of
parcel of what they're doing is trying
to demonstrate to themselves they still
have the power
to shape public opinion via narrative
and it's causing all these people left
to get even more
and more and more extreme and i'm just
relying on the fact that average
ordinary americans like you and i are
are as repulsed as you and i are by this
behavior
that they're engaging in the demands
they are making on
decent god-fearing america-loving people
we are not the problem
and yet we are portrayed as the problem
we're the enemy to these people it's
it's really scary you what happens if we
lose go back and look if we lose in 2016
if they
get the house folks i'm just going to
tell you
whatever trump wants to do is going to
stop it's going to be paralyzed
it's going to be nothing but in every
house committee that's that's relevant
inspections investigations subpoenas
they're going to go back and try to get
kavanaugh thrown out it's going to be
nothing but two years again
even with trump for having the audacity
to win
and the business of the nation is going
to be brought to a screeching halt in
the meantime they're going to try
to get rid of the tax cuts they're not
going to succeed in any of this because
the senate
is still going to be in the hands of
mitch mcconnell i officially call him
the turtle
because he moves so slow but he's
speeding up and he's really getting good
yeah he had a good run there for but he
ended judicial
he didn't know on gorsuch and kavanaugh
he was great
uh but i i still think trump
that's in whom i have in terms of the
politics of this
i still have implicit trust i i think
trump knows what he's doing here's my
question
we've had all this success in two years
obama
economically first president never met
three percent gdp growth in history
didn't want to this is the key
america doesn't deserve that yeah
america is so oppressive
so mean the minority so america doesn't
deserve sewer power status this is why
i wanted obama to fail in his view and
the elints give you
in the american left view america is
flawed america is the problem in the
world
america doesn't deserve it apologies
right but
economically 13 million more americans
on food stamps eight million more in
poverty
okay that's good that's mean more people
voting democrat more people depending on
government they
want that sean we have 14 states record
low unemployment
we have lowest in 69 a million more jobs
than people on unemployment right
look at who's benefiting
african-american unemployment
lowest ever hispanic unemployment asian
unemployment women in the workplace
unemployment
all of this success you're saying stops
if they get the house let me ask you a
simple question why
you just you heard him just go through
these statistics
the facts of the economic advancement
we've got more jobs than there are job
openings
a million we got a million more jobs in
their openings that hasn't happened
since 2017 who was president then wasn't
obama
the things you just heard sean go
through the democrats are angry at all
of it
why aren't they happy folks we are in a
roaring economy more people than ever
can get the job they want
they're getting raises they're being
bonused we have
people free to start their own
businesses the economy and every other
aspect of life in america is on the
upswing and a political party and
its voters are mad about it why
why couldn't you be happy answer is very
simple
if it happens as a result of individual
aptitude and application instead of
government
making it happen they're going to oppose
it this is the greatest
threat economic activity economic growth
self-sufficiency self-reliance people
learning
that the old rules of working hard and
applying yourself pay off
biggest threat to the american left in
the democrat party that there could be
let me ask you this why aren't they
happy about this i mean everybody ought
to because they lose their power
well of course here's where the question
answers itself you
you have been a leader in the
conservative movement in america i don't
know
no i don't know number one in the
conservatives that have with
the audience sustained and bigger
conservative movement is led by never
trumpers
okay in their mind if they had their way
where would we be
um not here hillary hillary would be
president if they underway
so here's my question you knew william f
buckley if you if you believe
goldwater was a wave if you believe
reagan was a wave
meaning the advancement of conservatism
if you believe newton the contract was a
wave
right where does donald trump i look at
his policies
i'm i've always been a conservative
never changed my views
might say it differently new
circumstances right but my fundamental
core beliefs have never changed
nor is nor of yours all these people
have said he's not a conservative
where like besides trade and i don't
even think trade he never planned to
trade he is implementing yeah look i
know these people i got another
30 years ago when this all-stars buckley
loved you buckley well i'll tell you a
story about him and where he would be i
thought you're going to ask me where he
would be on trump
but the answer to that is pretty simple
but
um they don't like trump because of his
manners
they trump is implementing issues that
these people have devoted their
lives to seeing past and they oppose it
and they're running away from it
it must never have been about the issues
it must be about the proper
appointment and the proper manners and
making sure we don't offend our liberal
friends in washington and so forth and
all that so trump does all of that
oh i can't abide this dude this is so
offensive to me i can't do this
meanwhile everything that's happening is
making america great exactly
as conservative said it would and they
don't want to be on the bus
he i say and i say this to people and
they say what
he governs as strong a conservative as
we've seen in our lifetime
well he does but i don't think the
divide in america is left and right so
much
and that would still be conservative
principles conservative principles it's
just
judges tax cuts regulations border
security
uh peace through strength it's what kind
of a country where the traditions of the
founding are are we going to go marxist
leftists i mean that's that's what this
is about
we don't have any in common with them
sean i hear all these people still say
we need to
cross the oil show we can cooperate show
them we can
show that government what do we have in
common what
name something we have in common with
any of the people
acting to destroy kavanaugh where is the
middle ground to compromise with them on
kavanaugh
they didn't even want to deny him to
allow him due process
zero and no corroboration they wanted to
destroy
his life and his family his career his
past his future and they tell us they
are the party of compassion
we've seen this before we've said it
bork clarence thomas you see it every
day and every election year we see it
every day
now every day donald trump i'm sure
you've taken your hits
you're you've taken your hits with you
yeah we see
everything anybody that they determine
is an effective
messenger of uh anything they disagree
with they're going to target
we could do 10 hours uh except you you'd
have to start getting paid
russia is going to hate